[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin einen schönen guten Abend
ihnen allen das sportliche in der
Sendung später mit Rudi Cerne hallo
guten Abend hier sind unsere Themen im
Überblick
Diskussion über die corona-politik in
der Regierung in Berlin mehren sich die
Stimmen die alle Schutzmaßnahmen
aufheben wollen
skeptische Ausblick wegen der hohen
Energiepreise und der Inflation erwartet
die deutsche Wirtschaft ein schwieriges
und verheerendes Winterchaos in den USA
sterben fast 60 Menschen in Eis und
Schneestürmen
[Musik]
kaum erkennen Experten ein Ende der
corona-pandemie in Deutschland
diskutiert die Politik über ein
schnelles Ende der
corona-schutzmaßnahmen während der FDP
und Union genau das fordern bleiben SPD
und Grüne vorsichtig Ärzteverbände
sprechen sich gegenlockerungen aus
aktuell gilt bundesweit eine
maskenpflicht im öffentlichen
Fernverkehr im Krankenhäusern
Pflegeeinrichtungen und Arztpraxen der
Rest ist Ländersache mehr von Winni
Häscher
Karl Lauterbachs neuer Dienstsitz hat
schon Post bekommen von nebenan der
Justizminister hat geschrieben die
Pandemie ist die Ausnahme Freiheit ist
die Regel wir sollten angesichts der
erfreulichen pandemischen Entwicklung
zum Regelfall zurückkehren und die
bundesweiten Schutzmaßnahmen außer Kraft
setzen die corona-maßnahmen gelten
eigentlich noch bis April so stets im
Infektionsschutzgesetz wenn Herr
Buschmann jetzt appelliert zu diesem
Gesetz was er selber mit beschlossen hat
dann appelliert er an die Länder ich
würde sagen wir erleben jetzt noch vier
Monate Abschiedstournee
desinfektionsschutzgesetzes und wenn es
dann keine Mutation gibt dann wird es
auch wirklich in die Phase der
Eigenverantwortung übergehen müssen ich
bin eindeutig dafür dass wir aus der
maskenpflicht in einer Masken Empfehlung
übergehen sollen wie es bereits in
vielen Ländern der Welt auch stattfindet
Deutschland wird jetzt nicht waghalsiger
oder als erstes Land diese Maßnahme
betreiben sondern andere Länder haben es
bereits vorgemacht Hintergrund des neuen
Ampel Streits ist ein Interview des
Virologen Christian er hatte dem
Tagesspiegel gesagt die Pandemie sei
vorbei Corona werde endemisch trete also
regionaler auf zudem hatte er vor
Belastung der Krankenhäuser in diesem
Winter gewarnt so sehen es auch
Mediziner das bedeutet ja nicht dass
atemwegsviren plötzlich ungefährlich
werden und wir sehen zum Beispiel auch
an China das Omicron natürlich extrem
hohe Sterblichkeit hervorrufen kann in
einer Bevölkerung die nicht so gut
immunisiert ist wie unsere deswegen ist
es glaube ich noch mal wichtig zu
betonen dass die Pandemie zwar ausläuft
aber dass wir weiterhin natürlich auch
eine hohe Belastung in den
Krankenhäusern haben seinem Kollegen
Buschmann hat Karl Lauterbach schon
geantwortet das Beenden aller Maßnahmen
wäre leichtsinnig Debatte vertagt sicher
noch nicht beendet
also Deutschland debattiert über ein
Ende der Pandemie China kämpft aktuell
mit einem dramatischen Corona Ausbruch
nach dem Ende ihrer nullcovit-politik
schießen die Infektionszahlen rasant in
die Höhe fast
250 Millionen Menschen sollen sich
seitdem angesteckt haben Kliniken und
Krematorien Arbeiten am Limit welche
Auswirkungen diese Entwicklungen auf uns
haben können dazu Christian Volk
lange Schlangen vor einem Krematorium in
Peking hier arbeiten sie seit kurzem
rund um die Uhr wir drehen mit
verdeckter Kamera eine
Abschiedszeremonie für Angehörige gebe
es nicht mehr sagt dieser Mitarbeiter
wir müssen der vielen Einäscherungen
erst mal her werden dass diese riesige
corona-welle auch gefährlich für
Deutschland wird davon geht das
Gesundheitsministerium derzeit nicht aus
auch corona-test für Reisende aus China
sind nicht geplant wenn diese Welle nach
Deutschland schwappen würde trifft sie
auf eine in Deutschland die immune
Bevölkerung wir haben
durch die verschiedenen Wellen die wir
durchlaufen haben und vor allem auch
gerade durch die letzte herbstbälle doch
da eine sehr starken Schutz aufgebaut
und China öffnet weiter ab dem 8 Januar
keine Quarantäne mehr für Einreisende
durch mehr Verkehr könnte sich die Welle
vor allem in ärmeren Ländern ausbreiten
insgesamt sind auf der Welt Länder
natürlich stärker gefährdet bei denen
die vulnerable Bevölkerung nicht adäquat
geschützt ist sondern so dass es da auch
wieder vermehrt zu schweren verläuft und
Todesfällen kommen könnte eine
Herausforderung auch für die
Weltwirtschaft früher waren in China
lockdowns für die gestörten Lieferketten
verantwortlich heute sind es Millionen
corona-fälle
auf diese Änderung konnte sich niemand
einstellen damit hat auch praktisch
niemand gerechnet dass das ist jetzt
innerhalb von 60 Tagen der vielleicht
radikalste Kurswechsel den wir überhaupt
in der Pandemie Bekämpfung auf der
ganzen Welt gesehen haben insofern sind
Unternehmen da gut beraten jetzt erstmal
auf sich zu fahren wie sich das beim
auswirken wird während die Börsen
positiv auf die Lockerungen reagierten
müssen sich Unternehmen wohl auf
unzuverlässige Lieferungen und
schwierige Monate einstellen
die Deutsche Krankenhausgesellschaft
befürchtet im kommenden Jahr eine
Pleitewelle bei den Kliniken des lasse
sich kaum noch stoppen sagte ihr Chef
Gerald Gas dem redaktionsnetzwerk
Deutschland in vielen Regionen würden
die Auswirkungen spürbar werden nach
einer Umfrage rechnen fast 60% der
Kliniken am Ende des Jahres mit roten
Zahlen
Energiekrise gestörte Lieferketten und
Personalmangel wenig überraschend
schätzen führende Wirtschaftsverbände
die Aussichten für 2023 schlechter ein
als vor einem Jahr trotz des Gegenwindes
rechnet man aber nur mit einer
mildenrezession mehr dazu von Lother
Becker
mitten in der Energiekrise nahm diese
jeansfabrik in Mönchengladbach die
Produktion auf eine moderne Textilfabrik
in Deutschland neu gedacht um auf
Lieferengpässe reagieren zu können von
vornherein nachhaltig konzipiert
tatsächlich haben wir eben durch den
Einsatz von erneuerbaren Energien
beziehen wir aus einem Windpark in der
Nähe aus Wachtendonk unserem Strom und
eben durch Solarzellen auf dem Dach sind
wir autark und haben dadurch von
gasengpässen glücklicherweise ja keine
Einbußen eine neue standortstrategie
entstanden in pandemiezeiten die sich
jetzt in der Krise bewährt denn gerade
schwer kalkulierbare Energiekosten
trüben die Aussichten der deutschen
Wirtschaft enorm ein Blick auf die
Stimmung vor einem Jahr wichtig dabei
die schlechten Aussichten waren es
damals sechs Branchen die kritisch in
die Zukunft blickten sind es jetzt 39
auch das nächste einigermaßen erträglich
wird hängt sehr davon ab dass die
Investoren ihrer Erwartungen
stabilisieren können dass Deutschland
das Europa auch unter den verändern
Energiekosten der attraktiver Standort
bleiben kann
während 2022 noch 24 Branchen mehr
investieren wollten beabsichtigen dass
2023 nur noch acht immerhin 22
Wirtschaftszweige wollen gleich viel
investieren wie im Vorjahr
verhaltene Optimismus trotz mäßiger
Aussichten die Pandemie Erfahrung der
Wirtschaft könnte sich auszahlen die
Jobs in Deutschland scheinen relativ
sicher zu sein immerhin eine gute
Nachricht in wirtschaftlich schwierigen
Zeiten
neues Jahr neue Regeln 2023 treten
einige Änderungen in Kraft für
finanzielle Entlastungen und mehr
Klimaschutz zum Beispiel das 49
euro-ticke das gilt ja deutschlandweit
im Nahverkehr kommt aber wohl frühestens
im März schon ab Januar müssen sich
viele Vermieter an der klimaabgabe ihrer
Mieter fürs Heizen beteiligen je weniger
klimafreundlich das Haus desto mehr muss
der Vermieter übernehmen und auch
Studierende bekommen eine
energiepauschale einmalig 200 € über
weitere Änderungen jetzt Markus
wolfhöfer
lange gerungen wurde um die Strom- und
gaspreisbremse durch sie bekommen
Gaskunden für 80% ihres
vorjahresverbrauchs einen Bruttopreis
von 12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde
garantiert beim Strom sind es 40 Cent
hier Kilowattstunde mit der Entlastung
können Bürger ab März rechnen dann
rückwirkend auch für Januar und Februar
gleichwohl muss man hier immer im
Hinterkopf behalten wir bewegen uns auf
dem sehr hohen Niveau das heißt unterm
Strich wenn ich meinen
Verbrauchsverhalten nicht verändere
werde ich letztendlich doch das Doppelte
zahlen als noch im Vorjahr neu auch das
Bürgergeld es löst Hartz IV ab die
Bezüge in der Grundsicherung steigen um
mehr als 50 Euro alleinstehende erhalten
künftig 522 Euro
mehr gibt es außerdem beim Kindergeld es
steigt einheitlich auf 250 Euro pro
Monat und Kind
und auch das Wohngeld steigt auf 370
Euro monatlich zudem sind deutlich mehr
Menschen antragsberechtigt
Restaurants und Cafés müssen künftig
auch Mehrwegbehälter anbieten für
Speisen und Getränke zum Mitnehmen
ausgenommen sind Betriebe mit weniger
als fünf Angestellten sie müssen jedoch
mitgebrachte Behälter auf Wunsch
befüllen
weniger Förderung gibt es bei E-Autos
der Umweltbonus für Plug in Hybride
fällt komplett weg der Zuschuss für
reine Elektroautos singt bislang zahlten
Staat und Hersteller dafür bis zu 9000 €
unterm Strich bedeuten die Änderungen
überwiegend Entlastungen für die Bürger
teuer bleibt der Alltag für viele aber
trotzdem
von Atomausstieg über Rentenerhöhung bis
Wohngeld was ich alles im kommenden Jahr
ändert können Sie bei uns online noch
mal genau nachlesen jederzeit in unserer
ZDF heute App
ja diese Reaktion aus Moskau war
erwartet worden russlands Präsident
Putin hat per Decret Ölexporte in Länder
verboten in denen einen preisdeckel zur
Anwendung kommt den hatte die EU Anfang
des Monats sehr beschlossen der Maßnahme
haben sich die G7 Staaten Australien und
Norwegen angeschlossen die Obergrenze
gilt für Öltransporte per Schiff und ist
eine der Sanktionen des Westens gegen
Russland
Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine findet
auch im Internet statt ukrainische
Experten zählten seit Jahresbeginn
4.500 Cyberangriffe vor allem auf den
Energiesektor und auf militärische
Einrichtungen in der Nähe von saporizia
schlugen auch wieder Raketen ein hier
wurde in der Nacht eine Schule zerstört
Opfer gab es nicht durch die Wucht der
Explosionen wurden auch Häuser in der
Umgebung beschädigt
vielleicht wie keine andere ukrainische
Stadt steht Botschaft für die brutalen
Gräueltaten in diesem Krieg nachdem die
russische Armee im April aus dem Käfer
vor Ort abzog bot sich ein Bild
äußerster Grausamkeit hunderte Leichen
wurden entdeckt teils verscharrt andere
offenbar exekutiert lagen gefesselt auf
der Straße für die Menschen bis heute
eine quälende Belastung eine Brühl war
dort
anders Grauen in der jablonska-straße
erinnern heute nur noch Blumen
wir sind in Butcher einem Ort der zum
Symbol geworden ist für das
Unvorstellbare
ich ja wir haben uns im Kindergarten
versteckt als die russischen Soldaten
reingekommen sind
da lag eine Leiche eine Frau in dieser
Straße lagen noch viele andere Leichen
war zu Hause als die Russen kam ich
hatte meine Kamera im ersten Stock
erzählt er uns
am 27 Februar hat er diese Aufnahmen aus
seinem Wohnzimmer gemacht russische
Soldaten russische Panzer direkt vor der
Haustür sie bleiben bis Anfang April
hinterlassen Zerstörung Chaos und
Menschen die bis heute zutiefst
traumatisiert sind
man hat einen meiner Nachbarn getötet
dann den zweiten aus diesem Treppenhaus
noch einen das haben wir erlebt so war
das
Valeri ist jetzt in ärztlicher
Behandlung nur mit Medikamenten kann er
zur Ruhe kommen sagt er aber der Krieg
geht weiter auch für die Menschen in
Botschaft geschunden kriegsmüde sind
viele hier warten vor allem darauf dass
die russischen Angriffe auf die
Infrastruktur aufhören oder dass der
Krieg zu Ende geht und die Heizung
funktioniert das ist das einzige jetzt
hat man andere Wünsche als man sie
früher hatte
und dann trägt sie den Eimer mit Farbe
in Ihre Wohnung weitermachen nach vorne
schauen auch in Botschaft
im west-balkan nehmen die Spannungen
zwischen Serbien und dem Kosovo wieder
zu militante Serben haben im Norden des
Kosovo erneut Straßen blockiert auf der
anderen Seite der Grenze in Serbien
versetzt der Präsident Vucic die Armee
in höchste Alarmbereitschaft ziel sei es
die im Kosovo lebenden Serben zu
schützen diese weigern sich seit Jahren
genau wie Serbien den Kosovo als Staat
anzuerkennen
jetzt in die USA wo Schneesturm Elliot
inzwischen abgezogen ist und das Ausmaß
der Kältewelle zunehmend sichtbar wird
mindestens 58 Menschen kamen ums Leben
und es könnten noch mehr werden
betroffen vor allem die Bundesstaaten
entlang der Grenze zu Kanada die
Temperaturen sanken deutlich unter -30
Grad besonders dramatisch ist die Lage
im Buffalo die Stadt war über die
Feiertage von der Welt eine Außenwelt
abgeschnitten
Sturm Aliens eiskalter Griff
unübersehbar am Lake eri tiefgefroren
aber wenigstens nichts zerbrochen weder
Fenster noch Wasserrohre meint
Eigentümer Kevin holt
ausgraben ist angesagt zu dem 1,20 m
hohen Schnee kamen in der vergangenen
Nacht noch mal 30 cm dazu und je weiter
die Helfer in das Umland von Buffalo
vordringen desto mehr Todesopfer
entdecken Sie
unglücklicherweise finden wir weitere
die erfroren sind
Menschen starben auch weil die
Rettungsdienste nach Notrufen einfach
nicht durchkamen die Familie tistel
verließ ihr Haus weil Strom und Heizung
ausfielen ihr Auto blieb stecken die
Feuerwehr konnte sie retten Weihnachten
ganz anders als geplant aber sogar mit
ein paar Geschenken für die Kinder und
neuen Freundschaften mit ihren Rettern
an manchen Flughäfen sitzen Reisende
seit Tagen fest auch heute wieder
tausende von Flügen gestrichen kaum
Infos von den Fluggesellschaften
ich bleibe noch ein paar Tage bei meinem
Vater und rufe meinen Boss an das ist
mir leid tut und dann noch das Gepäck
Chaos wer seinen Anschlussflug verpasst
sucht nun verzweifelt nach seinen
Koffern oft seit mehr als 12 Stunden weg
kommen sie auch nicht ähm ich bin
unglaublich frustriert es tut weh weil
ich meinen Vater nicht sehen kann
bald schon soll der Strom wieder da sein
die Lage sich normalisieren aber diese
weihnachtschuh viele schlechte
Erinnerungen an Sturm Elliots eiskalten
Griff
und weiter nach New York City die
Weltmetropole die so schwer vom
Coronavirus getroffen wurde eine Stadt
die aber unbezwingbar zu sein scheint
der Terror von Nine eleven das Beben der
globalen Finanzkrise immer wieder ist
New Yorker aufgestanden ein Film unseres
Korrespondenten Johannes Hano ab heute
in der ZDF Mediathek hier ein kleiner
Vorgeschmack das ist ein Streifzug durch
eine Stadt von der viele glaubten sie
würde sich nach corvideo nicht mehr
erholen New York City die Weltmetropole
mit Häuser Schluchten aus Stahl Glas und
Beton im April 2020 sterben mehr als
1000 Menschen am Tag heute zwei Jahre
später platzt die Stadt wieder aus allen
Nähten fasziniert sie wieder Besucher
aus der ganzen Welt
und der weit geht so
dreht sich die ganze Zeit ich will schon
jetzt wieder zurückkommen New York ruft
mich komm wieder komm wieder ich zeig
dir mehr
überall in der Stadt entstehen
wundersame faszinierende Orte arbeitet
New York in ihrem Mythos der
unbezwingbaren Weltmetropole waren es
früher Filme und Fernsehserien die den
Mythos immer wieder neu belebt haben
werden jetzt Orte geschaffen für die die
heute wichtig sind die Influenza der
Generation selfie
jedes Foto ist kostenlose Werbung auf
Instagram oder tiktok du möchtest also
so viele Leute wie möglich anziehen mit
so vielen Followern wie möglich um
kostenlose Werbung zu bekommen alles ist
Werbung
wir treffen uns mit Menschen die nicht
lang fackeln die Regeln dehnen und dabei
Verantwortung fürs eigene Handeln
übernehmen
Charakterzüge der New Yorker die die
Stadt am Leben halten
nach nine eleven oder kurvit und all die
wirtschaftlichen Probleme die wir hatten
bevor du dich versiehst ist alles wieder
weg egal was war
immer wieder wurde diese Stadt in die
Knie gezwungen immer wieder ist sie
aufgestanden sie ist und bleibt ein Ort
der Hoffnung für die die ihren Träumen
nachjagen
so wir sind beim Sport und bei Rudi
Cerne und bei den englischen Kickern die
haben keine weihnachtsbauspause genau
gestern rollte nämlich der Ball
traditionell müssen die Spieler der
Premier League nämlich auch am zweiten
Weihnachtstag ran und
tabellenspitzenreiter FC Arsenal hat
seinen guten Lauf fortgesetzt gewinnt
trotz 0:1 Rückstand hoch verdient mit
3:1 gegen West Ham United
westham entwischt den rot gedresten
Tabellenführern von Arsenal in der
ersten Hälfte eine einziges mal genug
für einen faul Elfmeter wenn Rama mit
der schmeichelhaften Pausenführung der
Außenseite
Arsenal entschlossen aus der Kabine
zurück und lange dauert es dann nicht
mehr bis ödega den Ball überhaupt nicht
gut aufs Tor bringt dafür rein zufällig
aber zu Saka England WM Spieler zum 1:1
Arsenal jetzt mit dem Schwung mit dem
der Londoner Club vor der WM an die
Tabellenspitze stürmte Martinelli mit
dem 2:1 spielt gedreht das begeistert
auch Arsenal Trainer Legende asienwanger
und der schönste Treffer folgt noch ein
ketia zum 3:1 Endstand Arsenal setzt
sich an der Spitze der Premier League
fest
und rechtzeitig zum Start der
Vierschanzentournee hat sich Andreas
Wellinger wieder fit gemeldet der
Skisprung Olympiasieger hatte die
Weihnachtstage genutzt um seine
Sprunggelenksverletzung auszukurieren
morgen beginnt in Oberstdorf die
Qualifikation fürs Auftakt springen ja
und genau das und weiteren Wintersport
zeigen wir Ihnen morgen ab 11 Uhr 15 Uhr
in Sportstudio live
Skirennläuferin Micaela shiffrin gewinnt
das erste Rennen nach den
Weihnachtstagen und baut ihre Führung im
Gesamtweltcup weiter aus im Riesenslalom
von Semmering in Österreich sieht die
US-Amerikanerin auf dem Zauberberg nach
einem couragierten und dynamischen Lauf
vor der slowakischen Slalom
Olympiasiegerin Petra milhova die
Technik Spezialistin feiert damit
bereits ihren vierten Saison Erfolg
das war der kurze Sport heute danke dir
Rudi wir können Ihnen sagen das Wetter
bleibt relativ mild im Norden regnerisch
im Süden trocken ob es bis zum
Jahreswechsel bleibt das erfahren Sie
gleich von Katja hornefall
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach im heute
journal Interview ab 21:45 Uhr mit Wolf
schmiese so viel von uns danke und noch
ein entspannten Abend für Sie
[Musik]
guten Abend eine Kaltfront hat
Deutschland überquert und so lagen die
Temperaturen heute einige Grad unter
denen von gestern jetzt kommt ein neues
tieferant schon hier über den britischen
Inseln können Sie das Erkennen das ist
das Tief Janina und das bringt neuen
Regen mit der bereitet sich heute Nacht
zwischen dem Niederrhein und der
Ostseeküste aus sonst ist es aber noch
locker bewölkt und hin und wieder bildet
sich auch Nebel die Temperaturen sinken
in Bayern in den leichten Frost von -1 -
3 Grad am Boden frostig kann es aber
auch hier zwischen der Ostseeküste und
dem Oberrhein sein bei
Tiefsttemperaturen zwischen drei und ein
Grad milder bleibt die Nacht im
Nordwesten bei 6 bis 4 Grad und die
Höchsttemperatur morgen liegen zwischen
4 Grad hier in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen
der Nacht zieht weiter nach Osten
nachmittags kann sich dann hier an der
Nordseeküste schon wieder die Sonne
zeigen in der Mitte und dem Süden das
dagegen trocken und südlich der Donau
sehen die Sonne auch mal häufiger
Donnerstag und Freitag geht es
wechselhaft bei uns weiter im Osten gibt
es mehr Sonne im Westen eher
Regenschauer und der Silvestertag wird
ungewöhnlich mit guten Abend